donc les petites les deux petits
le rendez-vous des chineurs et de retour
amateur Dar ou simple curieuse se
retrouve sur l'île des Impressionnistes
pour la Foire de Chatou jusqu'au 19 Mars
1023 argenterie meuble ou encore
sculpture ce côtoient pêle-mêle des
petits bibelots bon marché aux pièces de
musée chacun petit trouver son bonheur
et on voyage dans le temps nous passons
d'un stand dans un autre de l'univers en
tout autre univers on peut trouver de
tout sur la foire de château on peut
trouver des objets à 5 euros des objets
bien plus cher
sans limite du prix quoi pratiquement
présent depuis une quinzaine d'années
sur la brocante c'est antiquaire propose
des articles anciens venus du monde
entier chaque pièce parfois vendue
plusieurs milliers d'euros
s'accompagnent d'un certificat
d'authenticité vous avez ici un vase
gousse d'ail chinois de 2000 ans d'âge
en bronze une très très belle patine qui
était réservée aux offrandes à cette
époque-là avec des vins de France
moment de convivialité et de partage
autour de l'histoire les objets à chaque
édition près de 30 000 visiteurs arpente
les allées parfois à la recherche de la
perle rare ça fait 30 ans qu'on habite
sur la région parisienne et donc tous
les ans et deux fois par an on vient on
vient à la foire de Chatou trouver des
objets insolites et des antiquités sur
le sur les objets sportifs c'est un peu
comme les pour les paysans quoi c'est le
salon agricole des brocs et on appelait
on a plein de potes on s'achète entre
nous étant à Granville j'ai beaucoup de
clients qui sont à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
dans le 70 dans le vin dans l'ouest de
Paris et qui descendent sur la Bretagne
donc en fait c'est un suivi c'est un
suivi de clientèle et puis voilà près de
300 exposants professionnels participent
à 700 4e foire de Château aviochiner la
prochaine édition aura lieu en septembre
[Musique]